[Music]
in this video my aim is to give you the
basic understanding of the terms virtual
and real images it's a slightly long
video but it will be one of the most
interesting ones - I'm sure you'll enjoy
it what you see on your screen is a
mirror it has this plain and smooth
reflecting surface on one side it's
called a plane mirror because it's
reflecting surface is flat what are the
types of mirrors have you seen have you
seen this type of mirror well you must
have seen it on the stand of your
bathroom or maybe hung up there on a
wall this is not a plane mirror try to
move your hands over the surface and you
will notice it this is called spherical
mirror or more precisely spherical
concave mirror it is curved inwards it
is kept there as we use it mostly when
we are shaving now the obvious question
that must be coming to your mind is why
do we use concave mirror for shaving
instead of a plane mirror for the answer
to this question you have to wait for
our future videos for now we will be
concentrating on the plane mirror only
so let's consider this plane mirror
again when we stand in front of a mirror
we see an image of ourselves in the
mirror nothing surprising there why are
we able to see our image yes
it's due to the reflection of light in
fact it's due to multiple reflections of
light rays how the light rays from the
source are first incident on our body
they bounce off from our body and fall
on the surface of the mirror and again
gets reflected from there this reflected
light then reaches our eyes and we see
our image so what does this tell us yes
this tells us that a light ray can get
reflected multiple times the same thing
happens for every other non luminous
object as well if you remember my
initial goal was to explain what virtual
and real images are let me ask you a
question
this
image that you see here is it a real
image or a virtual one this image is a
virtual image in order to explain what a
virtual images let's first simplify this
image let's represent this boy with an
arrow pointing up and here is a plane
mirror you can assume the top of the
arrow to be the top of the head of a boy
now where is the image of the boy formed
when we see the image in the mirror it
seems to us that the image is formed
somewhere behind the mirror but there is
nothing behind the mirror right for us
the light rays seem to come from the
location present behind the mirror for
instance consider a few light rays
emerging from top of the arrow all these
rays are incident on the mirror and get
reflected back yes all the reflected
rays will follow the laws of reflection
you see that all the reflected rays are
moving away from each other that is they
are diverging but we know that the image
is formed somewhere behind the mirror so
let me extend these reflected rays
backwards and see what happens
we see that they meet at this point
behind the mirror and to us this is
where the top of the image appears to be
when we look at this point it appears to
us that all the light rays are diverging
from this point but in reality there are
no light rays behind the mirror this
being a smooth and shiny surface
reflects most of the light back and
almost no light reaches behind but yet
we have the perception that the light
rays are coming from the point behind so
we just consider the top of the arrow
here we can do something similar for the
remaining points on the object to get
the complete image so we say that the
image formed here is virtual or in other
words not real you can think of a
virtual image as an image which appears
to be formed in a position somewhere
behind the mirror but in reality it
isn't there a virtual image is formed
when the light rays diverge after a
flash
from the mirror every plane mirror forms
a virtual image this is the first
characteristic of the images formed by
plane mirrors images formed by plane
mirrors are virtual and not real so what
is the real image then and how are they
formed let's replace this plane mirror
with a spherical concave mirror why it's
because real images can be formed by
concave mirrors let's consider the light
rays from the same point of the object
incident on the mirror we see that after
reflection each ray is traveling in a
certain direction note that here as well
each ray obeys the law of reflection
what difference did you notice here
compared to the plane mirror reflection
in the previous case all the reflected
rays were diverging yes here all the
reflected rays after reflection are
intersecting each other at this point or
we can say that they are converging at
this point and the image of the top of
the arrow is formed at this point and we
can do something similar for the
remaining points of the object - we get
this image this is called a real image
it is the image formed when light rays
converge after reflection from the
surface one important thing we need to
know is that real images formed by
concave mirrors are always inverted we
will learn more about this in the future
videos you see that in this case the
image is formed on the same side of the
mirror as the object is real images are
always formed on the same side as that
of the object and light rays do reach
this position when we look at the real
image formed by a concave mirror it also
seems to us that the light rays are
diverging
but here the Rays actually are diverging
from a point in front of a mirror
whereas in the case of a plane mirror it
appears to us that the rays were
diverging from the point behind the
mirror so did you understand the
difference between a virtual image and a
real image when we look at a virtual
image it appears to us that the
right rays are diverging from a point
somewhere behind the mirror but in
reality they aren't as no light reaches
behind the mirror it's only our
perception and in the case of a real
image the light rays are actually
diverging from the point present on the
same side of the mirror in reality light
rays indeed reach this point
hence we call it a real image I
mentioned earlier that concave mirrors
form real images in fact they form both
real and virtual images and what does it
depend on it depends on the distance of
the object from the mirror we will learn
more about the real images formed by
concave mirrors in our future videos
first let's go back to our plane mirrors
this is only one of the characteristics
of an image formed by a plane mirror we
will see more in our next video
[Music]